what's up guys bang bang Bitcoin
continues his hot start to 2023. bitcoin
is up 43 to start the year which has
been one of the hottest starts since
2013. on top of that we continue to see
a highly illiquid Market with 70 plus
percent of all Bitcoin in circulation
being held by long-term holders now that
begs the question if the market is
highly illiquid what will be the
Catalyst for the next Bull Run we are
just over 400 days away from the next
Bitcoin having and in the past that
Bitcoin having has proven to be a huge
Catalyst an upwards movement now on top
of that it's important to always look at
Bitcoin compared to other assets and now
bitcoin's correlation to the S P 500 has
flipped negative for the first time
since the FTX collapse over the years
Bitcoin continued to enjoy a
non-correlation to the S P 500 and other
assets that means it wasn't highly
correlated but it also wasn't negatively
correlated it kind of oscillated around
zero now of course as we enter enter
into bull or bear times correlations of
assets tend to Trend towards one and you
see all assets going down in 2022 and
you saw many assets going up together in
2021 but Bitcoins continued
non-correlation to other assets is an
important feature it allows for
professional asset managers to put it
into their portfolio and provide a good
risk-adjusted return now of course
Bitcoin isn't perfect there's all sorts
of things that still need to improve but
another key part of the industry and of
the asset network is something like
Nostra or ordinals both of these are
products that recently have launched and
they have garnered immense attention
there are hundreds of thousands of
people that are using Nostra which is a
peer-to-peer relay system that allows
for social networking and the sending of
messages between individuals on the
internet and then something like
ordinals which has these inscriptions
that are essentially are nfts on the
Bitcoin blockchain that is also bringing
in tens of thousands of people to the
Bitcoin ecosystem system what we have to
remember is that Twitter is not real
life neither is YouTube ultimately the
free market is going to decide which
assets end up being adopted and which
assets end up Surviving over the long
term one of the best ways to ensure that
these assets continue to accelerate
adoption is to build all sorts of
products Services interfaces and many
other types of features on and around
them things like no Shrine ordinals is a
great way to do that and it just proves
stop complaining stop debating people on
the internet and just get busy building
I hope that you enjoyed this update and
I'll see all of you next Saturday